nací
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias queridos amigos
queridos compatriotas
aquí en parís
y en todo el territorio del continente
en los departamentos de ultramar y en
todo el extranjero antes que todo
gracias
[Aplausos]
después de cinco años
de transformaciones difíciles y buenas y
también de crisis excepcionalmente hoy
24 de abril de 2022
una mayoría de nosotros eligió confiar
en mí para presidir su república y
nuestra república durante los próximos
cinco años
[Aplausos]
celoso de milito agradecer alguno de los
militantes
voluntarios
y
compañeros de ruta y representantes
políticos que desde el comienzo de mi
campaña hicieron posible esta elección
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con toda su energía compartieron tantas
convicciones
y la verdad llega así desde el corazón
gracias sé lo que les dé un gracias
[Aplausos]
quiero
agradecer a todos los franceses y
francesas que en la primera vuelta y
ahora de la segunda vuelta
confiar
en nuestro proyecto por una arrogancia
más independiente por una europa más
fuerte
mediante inversiones y cambios profundos
continuaremos hablando de progresos a
todos mejorando la creatividad la
innovación de nuestro país y para hacer
de francia una gran nación ecológica
[Aplausos]
sé también que
muchos de nuestros compañeros nos
votaron por mí no para apoyar mis ideas
sino para frenar las ideas de la extrema
derecha
[Aplausos]
por eso aquí quiero agradecer
y decirles que tengo conciencia de que
ese voto moviliza de todos para los
próximos años
soy un depositario de su sentido y de su
apego
y del respeto de las diferencias que se
expresaron durante estas últimas semanas
[Aplausos]
también pienso en todos los compatriotas
nosotros que se abstuvieron
su silencio significa una negación a la
decisión y a esta negación también
tendremos que responder
a esta negativa vamos a responder
también por último sólo pienso en
quienes votaron por la señora lópez
quien debes quien está
decepcionada esta noche no hay que sin
para nadie no hay qué chiflar a nadie
siempre les he pedido eso
[Aplausos]
porque desde este momento
ya no soy el candidato a
presidente
[Aplausos]
y sé que para muchos de nuestros
compatriotas
que hoy eligieron
la cólera de los desacuerdos que los
llevaron a votar por ese proyecto
también tb deben encontrar unas
respuestas y se esa será mi
responsabilidad y la de quienes me
rodean
[Aplausos]
porque el voto de hoy
nos imponen considerar todas las
identidades y responder con eficacia a
las iras que se se expresaron queridos
compatriotas queridos amigos hoy
ustedes eligieron un proyecto humanista
ambicioso por la independencia de
nuestro país por nuestra euros a un
proyecto republicano en sus valores un
proyecto social y ecológico corresponde
un proyecto basado en el trabajo acción
y en la creación de un proyecto de
liberación de nuestras fuerzas
académicas culturales y empresariales
este proyecto
[Aplausos]
de este proyecto
quiero desarrollarlo con fuerza durante
los próximos años porque también soy
depositario
de las divisiones que se expresaron hoy
y de las diferentes dos velando cada día
por el respeto de cada uno no debe
ir siguiendo de verdad
luchando por una sociedad más justa y
por la igualdad entre mujeres y hombres
[Aplausos]
las culturas
para ello tendremos que ser exigentes y
ambiciosos tenemos tanto por hacer
y la guerra en ucrania está allí para
recordarnos que estamos atravesando
tiempos trágicos en donde francia debe
dar su voz debe expresar su vamos a
mostrar la claridad de esta decisión y
construir su fuerza en todos los campos
y lo haremos
[Aplausos]
también amigos - jerry tendremos que
expresar benevolencia y un estruendo
porque nuestro país todo sufre con
muchas dudas y con muchas diversiones
por eso tendremos que ser fuertes los
soles pero nadie será dejado al lado del
camino
[Aplausos]
tendremos que trabajar por esa unidad
que será la única que nos permitirá
vivir más felices en francia y enfrentar
los retos que nos esperan años que
vienen con los años que vienen no serán
tranquilos por todo es emocional pero sí
serán años históricos y todos juntos
sabremos escribirlos para nuestras
generaciones
[Aplausos]
queridos compatriotas
la ambición y la benevolencia
y por nuestro país y por todos nosotros
por todo eso quiero junto a todos
ustedes
enfrentar y abordar los próximos cinco
años esta era nueva no será la
continuidad del mandato que acaba de
terminar sino la invención colectiva de
un método nuevo para cinco años que
serán mejores al servicio de nuestro
país y de nuestra juventud
[Aplausos]
sacado con cada una de nosotros tendrá
una responsabilidad
aquí cada uno de nosotros
tendrá que comprometerse porque cada uno
de nosotros no cuenta más que sí misma y
esto
es lo que hace ser foxx de no hay pueblo
francés su fuerza singular esa fuerza
que amo profundamente tanto intensamente
y estoy orgulloso de servir nuevamente a
esta fuerza francesa
[Aplausos]
viva la república
y vivo a francia
[Aplausos]
[Música]